hello good afternoon welcome back who
was in my previous talk on the future
yes okay almost all of you those that
haven't you can watch the video when the
good folks at NDC put it out you know
you won't be missing something I'll be
putting in the necessary commentary just
to make sure that we're fully up to
speed in this talk we're going to be
focusing on how to implement the
architectural styles that I talked about
in my last talk all the code that I'm
gonna be showing you is available online
it's open source it's at that URL
github.com particular labs net core demo
as you can guess it is all dotnet
horrified up to the latest dotnet core
2.0 bits so if you've been looking to
use dotnet core in your projects this
has everything that you need so also
have the link to that at the end of the
presentation so you won't be missing
anything what are we even talking about
here so it's this idea of vertically
sliced architecture as opposed to
layered architecture now we're all
familiar with the concept of layered
architecture having UI talkin to some
kind of API layer which in turn talks to
business logic and data access logic and
databases where as I mentioned in my
previous talk that always ended up being
really tightly coupled no matter how
many layers we kind of put in there and
what I found over time is that
ultimately the better form of decoupling
is within a given layer rather than
between layers where parts of the UI are
often decoupled from other parts of the
UI and parts of the business logic can
be decoupled from other parts of the
business logic where in many cases the
best place to slice things down is not
the traditional microservices style
based on entities where we'd have you
know in the retail domain when we're
buying stuff online we wouldn't want to
have than a product service and a
customer service and an order service
that
based services model just results in a
whole lot of coupling with all of these
things talking to each other so when I'm
talking about vertically slicing things
it ultimately means even slicing down
those entities right down the middle
where something like a products name
might be in one of these vertical slices
but the product price could be in
another and the inventory levels of the
product would be on yet a third vertical
slice and the reason why something like
that could work is because we just don't
get business rules that say you need to
touch all those things in a common
transaction you won't have rules that
tell you if the name is longer than 20
characters then the price can't be more
than 20 dollars or you can't have less
than 20 units of inventory so and is
exactly through that kind of
decomposition that these vertical slices
kind of sort themselves out just another
example bear with me the customer entity
so things like a customer name and phone
number that sort of contact information
that could sit very neatly inside one
vertical slice but let's say the
customer status whether they're a bronze
silver or gold customer that doesn't
have to sit in the same service because
we don't have rules that state that if
the person's first name is John then
they can't be a gold customer which
would be a stupid rule in the first
place so and we don't have rules that
require both fields to take part in the
same transaction then we can put those
fields in different vertical slices and
then we can carry that all the way down
into the database because if we don't
need to have transactions that operate
on both of those fields together then we
can put them in two different databases
and not have to do a join and that gives
us the ability to actually scale out our
data tier by having different databases
for them and once we've done that kind
of separation all the way up top to the
UI and all the way down to the database
we can actually have these different
vertical slices
with totally different layers internally
where one of them has two layers in a
database and the other one has three
layers and as type of sharding model and
the third one is built more on a graph
type of philosophy we don't need to have
the same layers everywhere once we've
separated things out and each service
knows exactly which fields of data it's
responsible for then it can specialize
and decide what data model really makes
the most sense to me and how would be
the simplest way that I could fill that
fulfill the requirements around that and
that's with regards to the top to bottom
layers the final piece that we're going
to be seeing actually taking place in
this session is how and why
publish/subscribe communication between
these vertically sliced services is so
helpful and simplifies a lot of the
back-end complex orchestration that we
often have but because we got a lot of
code to go through I'm going to actually
start first and foremost at the top in
the UI so when you've got a UI like this
type of amazon.com product page as we
mentioned things like the product
catalog information the name of the book
the image of the book that can belong in
the yellow vertical slice the number of
stars the ratings of the book can belong
in the blue vertical slice the price can
belong in the green vertical slice the
inventory in the brown vertical slice
and all of that sounds awesome cool
great I get it but how do I build it and
that's what we're gonna be talking about
over here it's how do we take all of
those nice hand wavy arkad ivory tower
architect type things say well that's
great but does that actually work in
code so what we're gonna do is we're not
actually going to rebuild Amazon because
here I've got like 55 minutes left
so I'm gonna start with something
simpler we have the in that dotnet core
demo github URL that I gave you we have
a simple a shop type of environment
where we've got
products with names and they have costs
and they have shipping information and
descriptions and pretty much sort of the
the bare-bones building blocks of what
you'd expect on a product page in an
e-commerce type of environment so how
would we build something like this in
this composable type fashion so it all
starts with a generic web host project I
want to drive that point home because
the way that we traditionally build
these types of web based applications is
that we have this web project that has a
whole bunch of views and controllers and
those controllers talk to services and
the services return data and all of that
ultimately is orchestrated by this
top-level web host project what we're
gonna be doing here is different and
it's gonna look kind of odd because what
we have in that generic host project is
views that are bound to view models that
ultimately define how the page is going
to look
but the controllers the controllers are
really going to be these sort of simple
dumb type of objects that don't get any
data at all so here's what it looks like
this is the view for that product page
that we just saw or we've got a div
that's showing the image URL for the
picture of the product and the product
name and inside there we also have the
string that says oh okay this thing
costs this much money this is the
product description a view pretty much
like any other fairly simple and
bare-bones alright now all that's fine
the question here once again is great
how do we get the data into that view or
more specifically how do we populate the
view model so here's the controller that
doesn't do that this is the product
controller that exists in that generic
web host so what you see for the product
details page
that details method down there the only
thing that that controller does is
return the view doesn't go get the data
doesn't call any other services it does
nothing but return the view now you and
me looking at that saying well great
that's PowerPoint now show me the code
so that I'll actually believe that you
can build a generic dumb web host that
way that will still end up showing the
view with the data populated in it so
let's take a look at that here we go
so what we have here is this a shop UI
and we've got a whole bunch of projects
here what I've tried to do in this
session and most of the times people
have seen my talks I tend to rail
against the hello world samples that are
out there there are lots of great
technology talks that say hey this is
great this is awesome now let's go build
a hello world application or let's go
build a to-do list but it's not really
representative of a complex enough
domain that you can say would that
actually fit in the project that I'm
trying to build at work so we got a
whole bunch of moving parts here I'm
gonna take you through it bit by bit so
you can see how it all fits together and
why that's actually a good thing so
we've got this a shop UI thing at the
bottom and now I'm gonna show you the
view and the controller for that product
page all right so here's our details
product page exactly the same thing that
I showed you before alright and now here
we have our products controller which
again and we're looking at a product
page then the products controller is
going to be the thing that is invoked
and right there you see that the details
action is really just returning of you
so again you might be looking at this
saying okay great let's see that run so
when I run this you're gonna notice that
there's a whole lot of stuff that pops
up right now ignore all of these
back-end process type things because
we're gonna be looking at them a little
bit later what they're doing is they're
starting up the back-end API as well as
some of the pub/sub stuff that I alluded
to before that is going to be serving
the web UI that we have over here so
here is our web UI here is the details
page of a single phone again exactly the
same picture that I showed you before
and once again you can see is we see the
details and it's actually populated
there is data from somewhere else that's
coming into that even though our web
controller is not actually retrieving it
from anywhere so how does that even work
let's stop this for a second and talk a
little bit about the design behind this
all right so we saw just a little bit of
the code where's the magic that actually
makes all of this happen there's this
composition infrastructure that's
available as a part of the solution
all of it in the IT ops directory that
provides this kind of generic double
dispatch behavior that allows you to
create all sorts of plugins that hook
into the rendering of a page so it all
starts with two simple interfaces the
first is the route interceptor the route
interceptor allows any piece of code to
say I want to handle a web request if a
web request comes in call me so through
that it an object let's say from sales
or billing or shipping or whatever can
hook into the web request handling
pipeline and say I want to handle that
URL the other interface that's in there
is what's called a view model appender
because in essence what those objects do
they don't just handle a web request
what they do is they append data to the
view model of that page that's
fundamentally what a controller does
when you think about it it's not so much
controlling something it's getting data
into a view model so by implementing
those interfaces I can have two
independent NuGet packages three five as
many as I want that I toss into that
generic host run time and at startup
it'll load them dynamically into memory
and say oh okay
now I know what each one of you does
based on the fact that you implement
around interceptor if you model appender
etc when a web request comes in like
slash product slash details one then I'm
going to call you back and tell you do
your magic and then what is the magic
that they do ultimately they turn around
and update a view model so let's take a
look at their code and how they actually
do that work so back to our visual
studio so we've seen the generic web
host there actually isn't any
interesting logic in there but now let's
take a look at sales inside sales we
have this section called view model
composition I'll zoom into that and that
view model composition is that project
that I'm going to dump as a new get
package into my runtime directory of the
generic host and it has all of those
let's call them micro controllers
because micro services are such a cool
thing
we should have micro controllers as well
as micro services so let's take a look
at the product details view model
handler all right so in here
I think what we have is we've got the
we've got the order listened then
they've got the product list and we've
got the product price get handler all
right so what happens here is that is
that code big enough for everybody in
the back I've made it just about as big
as I can and still getting it into the
screen all right so you've got the part
that is looking to match the URL to say
is this a URL that I need to handle
that's the top method over here and the
bottom method is the part that actually
handles the request so that when a
request comes in what it does is it says
ok great let's pull out the product ID
from the URL let's go call my back-end
and get the data from that service and
here's the part where things go from
strongly-typed to more dynamically typed
this is kind of the magic loosely
coupled piece that we take the results
from my back-end API and put that data
into the view model and that's that view
model object that I get as a parameter
okay now here what we see is that that
microcontroller is only putting in the
price it's not responsible for anything
else it says I don't know what else
there is on this page and quite frankly
I don't care my responsibility is just
this little piece of the view model so
I'm gonna put my data in there now let's
take a look at another one so now we'll
go up to marketing marketing has its own
view model composition let's look at the
product details handler that we have
over there and once again what we see in
this matches functionality it's saying
if the request is for slash product
slash details slash ID that's something
I need to handle so it plugs into the
web request model
says I'm gonna handle that request how
do I handle that well when the request
comes in I'm gonna grab the ID from the
URL call my back-end to go get my data
and then map that data to the view model
and in this case I'm grabbing the
product name the product description the
image URL and I'm pushing that into the
view model now notice here that in terms
of the generic web project that we have
at the bottom let's see there's the
details page again nothing in there has
any awareness that those other projects
are even there the product controller
again no knowledge at all not making any
calls to those things if later on the
business says hey we want to do
something with I don't know ratings we
could have yet another service drop a
new get package into there and plug and
play we now have more functionality on
the website without having to update our
generic web project so here out of
convenience again I want to make sure
that I'm not pulling a fast one on you
what you can see in terms of the
dependencies is we've taken a dependency
on the shipping view model composition
the sales view model composition the
marketing view model composition but
we're not actually calling their code in
any way the only reason I'm taking these
dependencies is so that the output of
those projects gets copied into the
runtime directory so that when I do an
f5 at all just springs to life if I was
to work in a more proper production
ready DevOps type of pipeline I'd have
some kind of octopus deploy script that
is taking that generic host package and
the shipping view model package and the
sales view model package and the
marketing a new model package and
deploying them all up together without
having those dependencies in there but
because for this demo I wanted myself
and for all of
when you run it later on to just be able
to f5 and go alright so that's how this
magic is occurring and we're able to
have code from different packages from
different services all joining together
and engage in this type of view model
composition and now we've got a
beautiful screen in front of us that
shows the composition that we had before
next up a grid right so we've shown how
to show a single item now we want to
show a list of items or a grid of data
from multiple services so once again
bear with me so that I can show you the
code in PowerPoint so it's nice and big
this is the the view of the product list
page and what you can see again is that
we are looping over right there at the
top for each of our product in model dot
products alright so we know we have this
list of products and each one of those
products has a name and an image URL and
a price and all that kind of stuff ok
once again you saw the controller from
before that lists the index action of
the controller all that it's doing is
returning the view it's a dumb
controller and has no idea where the
data is coming from how many services
who needs to be orchestrated etc so
again let's run this and then we can
look at the code well I think you
already believe me that it runs because
we saw that before when we clicked on
the single page but once again here is
the products controller that's returning
the view here we have the products
index.html page that is showing us that
for each of our product in model dot
products and what we have in there is
the product name the product price the
product in stock all of that so the
thing about a grid
that makes it a little bit more
challenging is we don't just have the ID
in the URL right we can't just say each
of these services we'll go to the URL
and know which IDs to grab so that's the
challenge when we want to go and create
a list or a grid of things there needs
to be at least something that knows well
what are all the items that need to be
shown here in the first place
so here's how the composition works when
we're doing a grid we've got this orange
service let's call that marketing for
argument's sake and what it's doing is
it's going to its back-end and figuring
out what are the list of products that
need to be shown for that page now know
what it has over here it's not getting
back all of the product data because it
doesn't have all of the product data all
it's saying is I've loaded up the
product data that I know about and this
is the part where things get a little a
bit interesting because we're going to
use a kind of client-side message broker
this is also known as the event
aggregator pattern if you if you were
familiar with that term so it's raising
an event this is an in-memory in process
event in the web tier that's saying I
found this list of product IDs whoever
is interested you know do with it what
you like and now what we have is two
other services two other vertical slices
that are subscribed to that event that
says the products loaded and through
that they're able to get the list of
product IDs and once they have that then
they can turn around and go and talk to
their back-end and one of them says oh
okay let's go get the dollar value for
each of those product IDs the other one
says let's go get the inventory level
for each one of those product IDs
another one comes along and says let's
get the number of stars for each one of
those product IDs so again beyond just
that event
that is going between one service and
those other services there really is no
Orchestrator that knows how many of them
there are so now that each one of those
front-end microcontroller things has the
data that it needs they can start
pushing that data into the view model or
again one of them is putting in that
marketing type information of the name
of the product the image of the product
etc the other one is putting in the
prices the third one is putting in the
ratings and once the view model is full
then we can render the screen the view
and as far as the end user is concerned
it's gonna look like just a regular list
of stuff but again the trick here is
that there is no Orchestrator that is
tightly coupled to all of those pieces
we can very easily plug in a fourth and
a fifth vertical slice that will be able
to expand on the data that's coming to
the user and this is what gives us that
composed view model that list of
products where each field of data is
coming from a different service so let's
go take a look at that code to see just
how the publish/subscribe event stuff
works because it's like pops up if you
haven't done any type of event
aggregation it can seem a little bit
complex when you start out but once
you've kind of seen it once or twice
then you know it's fairly easy to see
how you do it a third time and a fourth
time okay so let's start out with just
that part of the the service that's
going in getting the list of them so
we've got the product list handler over
here this is from marketing where again
as we said there's the matches part for
it to say I need to handle this URL and
then in there it goes to its back-end
all right let's go get the list of
products and here's the part where it
maps that to some kind of dictionary so
it's got its back end list of products
and as we know we don't tend to bind the
model that we get from our back end
directly so we transform that to
something that is appropriate for a few
model and then this is the magic okay
that's the part where the service that
knows what the product ID is is raising
an event it's saying these are the
products that I've loaded whoever might
be interested in that again just to
drive this point home we're gonna go
look at the dependencies of the view
model composition project and what
you'll see over here is that it takes no
dependencies on any of their vertical
slice right it doesn't know that they're
there all it's doing is its raising that
event called products loaded and
something else will then react to that
so let's take a look at who reacts that
we've got sales that hat that is
responsible for the prices in this case
and inside sales we've got this view
model composition thing so the part that
we are looking at is the product list
get handler so there's a slight
difference here in terms of the
interface that it's implementing instead
of just handling the request it is
implementing the I subscribe to view
model composition events that's the way
that it engages with the infrastructure
and tells it look I'm going to want to
register a callback for when I need to
work on a view model so at the startup
of the page what it does is it gets
invoked by the infrastructure that says
hey you told me you need it to handle an
event on this page do your thing so it
talks to that infrastructure says I'd
like to register a callback for the
product loaded
event so page loads up that
microcontroller gets invoked as a part
of its initialization code it subscribes
to the event the callback that it has it
says when the event is raised then go
grab the product IDs then go call my
back-end to go get back the list of
information that my back-end has and for
each one of the product IDs that are in
there go and update the product price in
that view model alright so again what we
have here is a reactive microcontroller
for a page it's this type of NuGet
package that you can drop into the
generic web host and it will configure
itself and say which requests it needs
to handle and for each of those it'll
say what are the events that it wants to
handle and when those events get fired
how it's gonna actually grab its data
and update that view model so we can see
here again that sales and let's look at
one more which is shipping so right over
here we've got shipping and it's view
model composition and the product list
get handler and we'll see the exact same
thing inside shipping again you see the
namespace called shipping I'm not
pulling a fast one has a product list
get handler that is subscribing to the
view model composition event its
handling the product index page so the
exact same URL as all of the others are
and registers a callback for that same
products loaded event once it gets that
it goes to its back-end with the product
IDs does a request for the product stock
list and for each piece of data that it
gets back it updates the product in
stock property of that view model and
voila now we have a grid with all of
those pieces running together again you
can imagine that in the future when the
business
says now I want to have a customer
specific discount for every single item
in the list we can create a customer
micro-controller thing that is also
handling the product list URL it is
subscribing to the products loaded event
and then puts its own data into that
view model okay so now we can see how a
grid like this can be shown and most
importantly that we can do that without
having an orchestration layer that
everything is this type of pluggable
vertical slice that I can have you know
three of them five of them seven of them
where I can test each one of them by
itself I conversion each one of them by
itself I can deploy each one of them by
itself and I get all of the benefits of
micro services that you might have heard
about before but all the way up to the
UI I get this decoupling at the UI layer
I get the decoupling at the business
logic layer and I get the decoupling at
the data layer so again this is not
amazon.com but this is a working dotnet
core 2.0 solution that you can take home
and start playing with and seeing how
you could build something like that
yourselves let's move on what about the
actions right because it's not all about
queries we've got data that the user
wants to put into our system they want
to add items to the shopping cart they
want to buy items they want to cancel
orders they want to do stuff with our
system and not just query it now in this
example we're gonna see how we even do
composition for that so that it's not
necessarily just one controller action
that is handling everything because as
we know a lot of times there's a need to
do an orchestration for a given user
action we're saying if a user says I'd
like to buy an item yes there is the
regular sales process of buying an item
but we might have other types of I don't
know user click tracking type of stuff
that we also want to have in our system
now if all we have is just sort of one
big uber controller across the top and
it's orchestrating all those other
things again that creates a lot of
coupling and that's coupling on the
command side not on the query side so
we've gotten rid of a lot of the
coupling on the query side we're gonna
talk about how we get rid of that
coupling on the command side but just
for a second I want to pause that and
talk about something else entirely
the issue with handling these types of
commands that the user is performing is
that you know sometimes when production
gets under load bad things happen so
let's take a look at one of those
scenarios where we're using an HTTP API
for those types of commands and what can
happen to a system under load so we've
got data that's flowing into our system
people are clicking buttons saying I
want to buy an item I want to do this I
want to do that and we have our web
service at that front-end it's
processing that request turning around
talking to some kind of database saying
okay open up the connection go and put
something in the parent table go and put
something in the child table and as luck
would have it because our server is
under so much load is does the very
despicable act of shooting our process
in the head and bringing it back online
this is known as recycling your
application pool it sounds so much nicer
that way right oh I didn't shoot your
process in the head
I just recycled it recycling is green
and ecologically friendly but think
about what that
when your web server which is in the
middle of processing hundreds of web
requests talking to however many
database tables all of a sudden
disappears database is kind of sitting
there saying what just happened you open
up a connection you start doing these
sequel statements and you don't commit
you don't close your transaction you
don't end up cleaning up your connection
so it's sitting there waiting just so
that you know the default transaction
time out of a sequel server database can
be as high as 10 minutes not 30 seconds
most people think it's 30 seconds
because that's the HTTP timeout interval
but the database transaction timeout is
something else entirely so you could end
up with hundreds of zombie connections
in your database
that are left lying around for minutes
resulting potentially in other servers
not actually even being able to get a
connection to your database thus
resulting in some severe downtime for
your system so it's pretty bad when this
happens but it's kind of hard to stop
servers from crashing or web servers
from recycling their pool but eventually
the database says ok I give up it
doesn't look like these transactions are
ever going to commit I roll back so
whatever data we put into the database
is no longer there it's gone whatever
data we had in memory on our web server
similarly is gone because the process
has been recycled so now the $64,000
question is where's the data whereas the
hundreds of orders that the users were
placing on my web site the answer is
well it's not in the database not in the
web server what should we do
well the way that most developers handle
something like that is they'll say I'm
my problem the IT ops people should have
clustered things they should have highly
available eyes these types of things you
know I used best practices I used Web
API I used angular on the front end I
use transactions against the sequel
server database on the back end I did my
job
and if that results in data loss because
of downtime well then somebody should
pick some cloud provider that never goes
down
does anybody know of a cloud provider
that never goes down no I'm sure that
you know some of the vendors out there
will say no no we actually give you that
you just need to pay an arm and leg and
kidney and preferably your firstborn and
then we take care of that for you
everything will be highly available all
the time but if you're not willing to
give up your firstborn there's another
solution that works really well for
commands and that is to introduce a
little bit of queuing into the behavior
of the command processing and a little
bit of service bus technology over the
top such that when the user saying I'd
like to buy an item or is submitting
some other kind of command what we do is
we get that as a message into a durable
queueing system this could be RabbitMQ
if we're talking about on-premises this
could be as your service bus arrives
your storage queues if we're talking
about the Microsoft cloud this could be
Amazon sqs if we're talking about the
AWS cloud almost every type of
deployment environment that you can
think of has a queueing technology
queues are such a good idea in software
that they've been around forever and
there is just a plethora of
implementations available pick one but
having a durable queue is not always
enough you need something else that will
manage the transactions of pulling the
message out of the queue invoking your
own business logic for that where you'll
then go and talk to a database and
either it'll make use of some
distributed transaction stuff which for
example ms MQ and sequel server supports
or if you're using rabbitmq or Azure
storage queues or the type of queueing
technologies that don't support
distributed transactions then that bus
technology will use all sorts of cool
little implementation patterns like the
outbox you can google that and service
bus outbox
that gives you a kind of deduplication
safety that will make sure that a given
transaction is process just the one time
so if you want to figure out how that
kind of stuff works behind the scenes
that's not this talk you can go and find
the information in the documentation
online so that whenever something bad
happens whether you're processing server
crashes whether the database runs out of
connections whatever when all of that
rolls back not only does the database
roll back but the queuing system will
roll back that message meaning that you
don't lose any data the million-dollar
order that was submitted on your website
is back in the queue and then you can
process it again now there's a little
bit more complexity to how a bus works
but that's roughly what it is at a high
level and why you want to have one for
when you're processing data that's
coming in from your users so what does
that look like in terms of code in order
to send a message into a queue it looks
something like this you have some
controller and it could be that sales
controller or the pricing controller or
what have you that is handling that HTTP
request and you turn around for that
HTTP request and create a object in this
case we're talking about the record
consumer behavior message because we
want to track what it is that the user
is doing on our website and we take that
and we send that
into a queue so this API awaits session
dot send with a message object is the
end service bus wrapper for the queuing
system so it's really that simple two
lines of code to put a message into a
queue and it does all sorts of other
nifty things that we're gonna talk about
in a minute
now let's talk about the backend side of
it of what it means to handle a message
so here again we have the part of our
system that is tracking the users
behavior on the website where it is
implementing the interface
I handle messages of record consumer
behavior that's the message object again
and in our handle method it does the
actual work so what we're doing over
here in our sample just to make this a
little bit interesting is we're
simulating that we're doing some work by
putting in a task delay the reason that
we do this is so that in just a minute
when I show you how we monitor all of
these different processes that will
actually see some kind of load in the
system because when we don't have any
task delays it just runs too fast and
you don't get to see anything
interesting that's going on so now that
we've talked about that let's go look at
that bit of code the sending of the
messages the handling of the messages
and then from there some
publish/subscribe that's going to be
happening behind the scenes between our
services so on to code so for this
button remember what I said we want to
do two things the user wants to buy an
item and we want to record the consumer
behavior so what we have here I'm going
to start with the record consumer
behavior because that's what marketing
is doing marketing as a part of that
behavior that the user is doing has a
buy item post handler so again it's
implementing that view model composition
interface I handle requests that allows
it to say I want to handle when the user
clicks
the by item command in other words the
HTTP POST is by item for the URL called
slash product slash ID so again that's
our matches behavior for an action as
opposed to just for a query and then
here's that code that I showed you
before where what it's doing when the
user clicks that button is it turns
around and puts a message into a queue
ok so here we have one button click
handler from one vertical slice and now
what we're going to do is look at
another vertical slice that is handling
that same button click so we'll go into
sales and inside sales again we see a by
item process handler which again is
doing that I handle requests handling
the HTTP POST by item action for the
slash product slash ID and for that
button click what it then does is it
sends its own message saying the user
wants to place an order reiterating why
is this a good thing now I don't need to
have a big orchestrating controller that
I need to update anytime the business
says I want to do something else in
addition to what is already happening
when the user clicks buy item in other
words I can enrich the behavior of my
system for each user action without
having to change existing code from
other vertical slices I can continue
putting in new code that plugs into the
existing behavior of that system so now
let's look at what happens when we're
handling the place order command so
notice here I have the place order
command inside the
sails internal project so sails internal
is the place where I'm putting the
messages where sails front end code is
talking to sails back-end code so this
is just internal vertical sliced
communication without anybody outside my
slice knowing that I'm doing anything at
all so here's my place order command and
as you can see it's a fairly simple
object just a DTO with some get set
properties on it the order ID the
product ID etc and now when I look at
the sales API the back-end part of it I
have a message handler that is called
well actually this is the part where
things get interesting so what's going
to happen here is that I don't have just
any old regular message handler instead
what we have is a kind of longer running
process what we've discovered is that
when users go to buy stuff online
especially iPhones it turns out that the
sometimes cancel their order soon after
now although this is being recorded this
has never happened to me okay I have
never gone online when a new iPhone has
come out and immediately done an impulse
purchase of the new version of the
iPhone where five minutes later my
significant other walks by and says hi
hun what you doing and then I never
immediately said oh nothing and
immediately cancelled the purchase that
I had just not made now from the
perspective of the company they've
noticed that this is happening kind of a
lot for the new iPhones that we're
putting out there so when the user
clicks place order if we immediately
start going to the warehouse and getting
stuff
and charging the persons card and then
five minutes later they cancel their
order it's like ah now we need to refund
their purchase to the credit card but
unfortunately I still have to pay the
credit card company for the action that
we've performed and then we got to go
and take the iPhone out of the the bin
and put it back on the shelves it's
really a wasteful operation when someone
buys something and then immediately
cancels afterwards so we put some logic
in there to say after the user clicks
the buy item button what we're gonna do
is we're just gonna sit on that order
for a while just in case they cancel
their order soon after so the way that
we do that is that we have this thing
it's called a buyer's remorse saga and
there's this thing called buyer's
remorse is over in the solution but let
me just find that buyer's remorse thing
inside sales
okay so this is the cancel order part of
a okay we didn't actually put in the the
behavior there it is okay here I found
it sorry about that
intermediate black out of the speaker so
what we have here is an order acceptance
policy saga sagas are this feature of
in-service bus that allows you to
introduce a delay between the processing
of one message and another message so
here you can see that we have an object
that is started by a place order command
it also handles timeouts for when the
users buyer's remorse period is over and
it also can handle the cancel order now
we don't have time to delve into all of
the nifty things that sagas enable you
to do but what I'm going to do is I'm
going to run this so that you can see
that behavior in action that when I
click that place order button what's
going to happen over here is I'm going
to put in well actually what I'll do is
I'll just show you the the log output so
there's all of our backends here's the
front-end and once it pops up I'm gonna
go buy an item so let's go buy an iPhone
X I'm gonna click Buy Now and it says
your order has been placed when I look
at the my order section it says hey you
want to cancel your order like yeah go
cancel the order what's happened here
behind the scenes I'm going to pop up
sales
is that there's that thing in there that
saying the message handlers dot order
acceptance policy saga is now waiting
for the grace period to see if the user
cancels their order and because I did
cancel my order it then associate that
with the previous saga instance and then
knows oh okay great let's just get rid
of that order without telling anybody
and here we can see that our other
services billing API for example has not
received a thing it doesn't know that
any order was placed which is exactly
what we want to have happen so now what
I'll do is I won't cancel the order I'll
go in and actually buy my item and what
we'll see happening back in site sales
is that it has accepted that request and
it's sitting there right now I think we
were opening up a time out for about 15
seconds to say let's see if the user
canceled their order now if the user
doesn't go ahead and cancel their order
then the saga will spring back to life
and say oh okay it looks like they
didn't cancel their order
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
publish an event to say now everybody
can go handle this thing now here what
you can see is that billing has now
received that event the order accepted
handler has been triggered we've done a
publish that an order was accepted and
we'll also see that inside shipping
shipping has also received that order
accepted event now shipping is also
doing a saga and you can see how it
behaves there because it handles the
order accepted event and the order
billed event and associates those two
events together but ultimately all of
those things enable us to go and take
action behind the scenes why is all of
this pub/sub even important I've been
talking cohhd cohhd cohhd for a while I
want to zoom back out for a minute and
talk
about our higher level picture our
vertical slices again where again what
we have here is that lightweight pub/sub
happening behind the scenes the reason
that this is important is it allows us
to have multiple vertical slices
engaging in a given back-end flow
without creating coupling so when the
business says I want to award the
customer loyalty points for every
purchase that they make I can create
another vertical slice that is going to
subscribe to that customer build event
or the order placed event and have that
logic off to the side without making any
changes to the code that's already in
place that's the advantage that's what
I'm trying to achieve that ability to
grow my system functionality over time
without creating more complexity through
bigger orchestrations okay so that's the
point of all of this exercise now what
I'm going to do is I'm going to go
really briefly through some of the other
nifty things that happen when you use
messaging so really quickly message
processing failures it could be that
your database is down it could be that
DC realization fails when you deploy a
new version of your system into
production of course that's never
happened to any of you here but I'm
pretty sure that you know of somebody
who's had that problem once upon a time
queueing technology when it sees that
it's processing that message over and
over again and it keeps failing it can
bump that message out to a dead letter Q
we can do more than that
when using and service bus and the rest
of our service platform so when a
message fails we take that out of that
error cue put it into some back-end
process and show visualize a
on top of that and say hey a message
failed this was the specific message
type that failed here was the exception
that caused it to fail this is the
number of those types of messages that
have failed you might want to deploy and
roll back to the old version of your
system where everything was working okay
and then there's that button over at the
bottom there it says retry it so you can
send all of those 206 failed orders back
to be reprocessed again once again
without having lost a single piece of
valuable business data so this is
something that administrators really
start to appreciate when they need to do
continuous deployment you might have
heard of continuous deployment before
the problem that nobody seems to speak
about in continuous deployment territory
is what happens when you screw it up and
your system loses data you don't want
continuous deployment to equal
continuous data loss that would be a bad
thing right so this service platform
gives you a lot of that kind of safety
net other things auditing and tracing
most queuing systems give you the
ability to copy messages that are
processed somewhere else that's nifty
and great but when you have hundreds and
thousands of parallel requests from
different users all being audited
together and all of this asynchronous
pub/sub happening behind the scenes it's
really difficult to know what what
actually happened in the system within
service bus what we do is we decorate
all of your messages with a correlation
identifier so that when message number
two is published as a result of
processing message number one when we
audit that we store that trail of
breadcrumbs so that that way when you
have a given flow through your system
where place order resulted in order
accepted an order accepted trigger to
saga and then saga triggered something
else which triggered order
which triggered order shipped and you
have all of those events happening in
parallel for multiple users we can make
sense through these breadcrumbs across
all of the message headers taking all of
that audit stream putting it into some
kind of indexable database where then we
can create a nice kind of visualization
here is what happened in your system
that endpoint send a message over there
when over there we published an event we
triggered a saga that saga resulted in
this other thing and then we can trace
everything as it flowed through the
system in addition to that what's really
important when you have a queueing
system everything's async you still want
to know when the system gets slow with
traditional HTTP when the system gets
slow users complain because they're just
waiting for the page to load when you
start introducing messaging everything
that the users do is a Singh so they
don't even notice that things are going
slowly but you can have messages
building up in your queue and that can
be a problem so most of the queuing
systems will give you some element of
visibility into what that looks like
give you a quick peek at what that looks
like with RabbitMQ so RabbitMQ has this
type of management environment where it
will show you for each one of your
queues what is the number of messages
that are in there and if you want you
can drill into a given queue and see
ultimately the flow that's happening in
there now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to run the solution again but when
I run it I'm also going to include
something that generates some load so
that we can actually see this thing
running and doing something because I
can't press the button fast enough to
actually generate meaningful load so as
a part of this solution at the bottom we
have this thing called a load generator
so I'm going to bring that thing up and
what it's going to do is it's going to
start pushing messages you'll
see it kind of logging it's a sending a
place order message sending a place
order message etc and we can start
seeing in our back-end sales is chugging
along and processing those messages and
when I look at rabbit and queue where's
my rabbitmq we can see once RabbitMQ
wakes up again
well right now it's it's processing too
quickly so we can't actually oh there it
is RabbitMQ just woke up we see the
graph ticks up and it says oh ok you
know something is happening for that
queue but if we're looking across all of
the things we can't sort of get a good
sense of where things are for that
reason with part of the service platform
that you get within service bus we have
all of this type of information that
shows you as well not just the number of
messages in the queue it'll show you the
throughput of messages process per
second retries which is a really
important thing to monitor in your
system because it could be that
everything is processing okay but if it
takes 2 or 3 retries that could be an
indication that something's not designed
very well in your system right there you
saw that there was a blip at the bottom
that was in her shipping api where
potentially because there was a data
base deadlock or something like that
that is what resulted in the system
getting slower we also track the
processing time and this thing called
critical time critical time is a value
that says roughly speaking how long is
it going to take for the next message to
work its way through the queue and
complete its processing that can be very
meaningful when you're in an SLA
sensitive domain when it matters how
quickly you process things so there's a
lot of this stuff available as a part of
this broader platform and ultimately if
you're using Cubase systems you're
probably going to want to have these
types of things so again whether you're
using rabbitmq or MSM Q or sqs each of
them provides something you off
we'll require all of these types of
elements in place now getting to the end
of my time but I want to show you some
other nifty things so I talked about
visualizing the system and that's
performance monitoring my machine is
barely keeping up so all of this that
I've been showing you works across
multiple stacks so if you're on a sure
you can use Microsoft Azure service bus
you can use as your storage queues if
you're working on premises you can use
MSM queue you can use rabbit and queue
if you're working in the AWS stack you
can use SQS and even you can use sequel
server because sometimes people don't
want to install a queueing system they
just want to say can you make it work on
the database so ultimately you can get
all of that decoupling without taking on
any other infrastructure so one more
thing because I know I've been saying
hey this is not net core 2.0 and you've
just sort of taken my word for it what I
want to do and I know I'm a little bit
over time is I want to show it to you
now running on a Mac and then afterwards
what we're gonna do is we're gonna run
it on Linux running in AWS so the exact
same solution that you've been seeing up
until now but running the way that you'd
expect in production so David's got the
Mac and we're gonna switch over the
screen and away we go so what we have
over here is Visual Studio on the Mac so
when we're running this ultimately what
you're seeing here is the that same UI
that's gonna be popping up just give it
a second as we know that it can kind of
take a minute but again this is native
Mac development this is not Mac via
parallels this is none of that this is
actual
on a Mac dotnet core locally so you can
do all of your development with Dutton
core and again all of this is happening
with the pub/sub and with the
reliability and all of that so let's go
buy an item really quickly and see that
that process is working so we buy an
item we go into the orders page and
we'll see that there is an order there
and we can the challenge with running
Visual Studio on the Mac is that you
it's much more difficult to see the log
output of all of those consoles what it
does it just sets them up as little
console windows over there now that can
be a bad thing in the sense that it can
be difficult to see as the system is
running but on the flip side at least
you don't have 15 windows that open up
every single time you go and debug your
system alright so now we've run it on
the Mac running locally now we'll do
let's switch over and see it running on
Linux in AWS so what we're doing now is
we're in an Ubuntu shell correct
oh but still on the Mac though we're
gonna be from there going into our Linux
shell and from here we can now run our
entire solution so here we can see we've
got all of our dotnet projects in there
and we're gonna run these just by this
start all of solution script we can have
all of them spinning up to life so you
can see in those comments it's spinning
up the marketing API it's spinning up
the sales API it's spinning up the
billing API and now we can see we have
all of these dotnet processes that are
running so currently we're not having
any kind of log output as a result of
this but when we start putting some load
into this thing then we'll start seeing
the behavior happening so right now if
we look at the URL we can see that we're
actually
connected to the Linux thing so it's
remotely connecting you can't really
zoom into that but you the URL there is
net core demo dot particular dot in that
this is actually going and running
against that AWS environment so it's
connecting to that cloud hosted
environment all right now let's take a
look at the monitoring side of things
here we can see all of those endpoints
that are up and running in the cloud
they're not currently processing any
load that's not very surprising because
we haven't clicked any buttons but now
we'll do is we'll invoke that low
generator and we'll be able to see as
those messages are coming in let's
actually ramp up the the load a little
bit so that we can get some more
messages flowing in so right now it's
sending through just about six messages
per second in parallel and we can see
that each of those endpoints now has a
little bit of a spike as its processing
them so again what you're seeing over
here the exact same solution that was
running dotnet core on a Windows machine
and now running in Linux with all of the
monitoring and tracing kind of stuff as
before you also have service inside open
up ok so now for the final piece of the
puzzle as they say in Steve Jobs
terminology just one more thing so all
of this is great because I have a new
dotnet core project running Linux AWS
and everybody's happy with that but now
the business turns around and says you
know we have this old warehouse
management system that we've lifted and
shifted and we're running it in Azure we
want the new system that you've created
to subscribe to events from that legacy
system the only thing is our new system
is running RabbitMQ the old system is
running with Azure storage queues and
now we want these two systems to talk to
each other
so what we can do here hmm close that
down is go and look up that as your
website that's our warehouse management
thing that allows us to influence the
stock of a given item so let's switch
back to the UI of our shop and then we
can see that currently the galaxy 8 is
not currently in stock now we'll do
we'll go into our stock management
website we'll switch that and provide it
some stock and when we go back to our
website for the sales and we refresh
that what we'll see is that now that
item is in stock in other words we had
the published subscribe behavior
happening from the azure cloud into the
AWS cloud dotnet full framework asq on
one side going to cloud hosted RabbitMQ
running linux AWS on the other side and
all of that
is enabled by this end service bus thing
so when you're starting out on a project
whether you're talking about a brand new
system or a legacy system that you need
to connect to we try to give you that
layer of abstraction in this whole set
of tools around all of that that will
enable all of that to work so just to
wrap this up again all of the code that
we've shown you is available online here
github.com particular labs net core demo
whether it's the UI composition piece
that we started out with the
publish/subscribe piece the monitoring
tooling the error management all of that
is available online give it a try see
how it works I hope that this is giving
you an idea of how possible it is to
actually build and run and scale this
type of vertical slice architecture it's
not just a theory hand wavy thing that
you go to a conference and say oh that
sounds like a nice idea but I don't know
how to do that
now you have the code to actually
implement that and you've seen all of
the pieces of it from whether you're
querying a single item whether you're
querying multiple items whether you're
taking action when a user clicks a
button in such a way that you have a
truly decoupled solution so if you want
more information about how to find those
service boundaries because that's pretty
tricky as well there's a video of a
presentation that I've given at an older
NDC you can find the link to that there
bitly finding service boundaries where I
talk about the business analysis that
you'd be going through to be able to say
well what actually goes into which
vertical slice so I hope I've given you
a lot of food for thought and a lot of
code that you can take home and play
with and if you ever have any questions
feel free to ping me whether that's over
twitter or go to the particular net web
site and chat with us thank you all very
much and have a great rest of your
conference
[Applause]